bonsoir sauce blanche raison merci
d'être avec nous un accord temporaire de
trois mois donc toujours une
surveillance même réduite durant ce laps
de temps
iran - etats-unis qui doit faire le
premier pas après tout ce sont les états
unis qui sont sortis comme vous l'avez
dit en 2018 de cet accord et l'iran
attend bien entendu que les états unis
qu'on fait confiance par des actes leur
volonté de revenir dans cet accord et
pour l'iran césar ça doit être la levée
des sanctions économiques que les états
unis ont rétabli et d'ailleurs qui sur
le plan juridique sont peut-être un peu
fragile puisque la cour internationale
de justice il ya peu de temps
c'est reconnu compétent pour le moment
venu statuer sur ces sanctions
économiques
alors évidemment du côté américain on a
montré où aussi un peu de bonne volonté
d'abord en libéralisant les conditions
de circulation et diplomate iranien à
new york siège de l'onu
ensuite en retirant la lettre que
l'administration trump avait envoyé un
l'onu au conseil de sécurité pour
utiliser l'onu comme caution pour la la
remise de sanctions contre contre l'iran
c'était évidemment impossible puisque
pour ce faire les états unis utilisé à
une convention un accord dont il était
sorti par conséquent ils pouvaient pas
invoquer un article qui prévoyait dans
certaines conditions la remise de
sanctions et puis effectivement ils ont
également saisi au bond l'opportunité
d'une invitation par l'union européenne
et est également souhaitée par l'iran
pour que tous les partenaires à l'accord
puisse se réunir dans les prochains
jours dans les prochaines semaines pour
discuter des conditions dans lesquelles
les états unis pourront se réinsérer
dans l'accord et l'iran
appliquer toutes ses obligations dont il
s'était éloigné le ministre des affaires
étrangères iranien avait d'ailleurs dit
le 1er février
nous nous attendons que monsieur josette
borel le haut représentant pour la
sécurité et la coopération joue un peu
le rôle des chorégraphes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils règlent les petits pas que feront
les états unis et les petits pas que
feront l'iran puisque l'un et l'autre ce
défi du du partenaire du partenaire
adversaire et qu'il faut en effet
organisé la réinsertion de façon très
minutieuse
maintenant il y à un peu moins de trois
mois pour le faire alors qui a intérêt à
ce que les états unis ne reviennent pas
toute blanche maison dans l'accord de
vienne
l'israël israël a dit tout le mal qu'il
pensait de cet accord depuis depuis le
début il est clair qu'israël y relève
élections très prochainement au mois de
mars
monsieur netanyahou va certainement veut
dire que cet accord met en question la
sécurité d'israël d'ailleurs le chef
d'état-major dz salle de l'armée
israélienne a fait une déclaration tout
à fait étonnant il ya quelques jours
disons que si cet accord
revenez demain en vigueur peut
pleinement eh bien il est possible que
israël doivent défendre sa sécurité est
une déclaration assez menaçantes de la
part d'israël à quelques jours
d'élections législatives qui seront les
quatrièmes en peu de temps et par
ailleurs évidemment l'arabie saoudite le
fait - savoir mais n'a aucune envie que
les etats-unis et les autres partenaires
de cet accord reviennent dans une
négociation avec l'iran puisque l'arabie
saoudite et le grand rival de l'iran
pour le leadership du monde musulman
d'autres pays ne le disent pas mais
regarde avec attention ce qui va se
passer parce que comme l'arabie saoudite
la turquie l'egypte considère que si
l'iran devait un jour se doter de l'arme
nucléaire et bien eux aussi devraient
sans doute
le même chemin donc on est là devant une
hypothèse de prolifération extrêmement
grave alors l'accord de vienne qui ne
soit sauvée ou pas quel peut être
l'impact sur l'élection présidentielle
iranienne du mois de juin
dxo présidentielle c'est le 18 juin et
ce qui est sûr c'est que les modérés ont
déjà joué beaucoup sur cet accord mais
n'ont rien obtenu
puisque le pari de monsieur roy dit
lorsqu'il s'est lancé dans cette
négociation qui a duré plus de dix ans
kate et négociations terrible et bien
avait promis à la au peuple iranien que
les sanctions américaines et
occidentales seraient levés alors elles
ont été levées par les européens elles
ont été levées par le nu mais les
américains après les avoir levé les ont
remises puisque monsieur trump a dénoncé
cet accord et effectivement là je crois
que les modérés sont en mauvaise posture
d'ailleurs dimanche soir hier soir
lorsqu'on a annoncé l'accord que le
gouvernement iranien est l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
pour que les contrôles puissent
continuer tant bien que mal pendant
trois mois même s'ils sont un peu
restreint par les décisions de
l'assemblée et bien l'assemblée
l'assemblée nationale iranienne a pris
des décisions extrêmement brutales
contre le gouvernement iranien
interdisant aux ministres de monsieur
rohani d'apparaître dans l'hémicycle et
disant qu'il refusait de voter le budget
pour l'année qui vient à l'aller
budgétaire commence le 21 mars en iran
donc un conflit en effet entre un
parlement très conservateur et un
gouvernement modéré qui voulaient
aboutir un accord et qui veut obtenir ce
que la population demande c'est-à-dire
la levée des sanctions économiques qui
sont particulièrement dommageable le
niveau de vie a considérablement baissé
en iran il ya des pénuries dans certains
dans beaucoup de produits y compris des
produits pharmaceutiques et puis on est
en pleine crise de que vides et par
conséquent
une malédiction s'ajoutent s'ajoute à la
première merci claude blanche maison